There's an old story about how to catch
a monkey in case any of you are
interested in how to catch a monkey.
Now you now you're going to know how to
do it.
First you have to take a large,
narrow neck jar just large enough in
diameter at the top for a monkey to put
a tanned inside.
Then you have to fill it partway with
rocks so it's too heavy for the monkey
to carry.
Then you scatter some treats near the
jar to attract them and you put some
inside inside the narrow neck.
Gr a monkey will come along if you're
lucky and grabbed the goodies,
but he'll want the ones inside the jar
too,
so then put his hand in there and grab
what's in there.
And if you've set up your monkey truck
properly,
then he won't be able to get his hand
out because he's got the goodies.
Not Without unclenching his hand,
not without relinquishing what he
already has.
The monkey coucher can just walk over
and just pick up the monkey because the
monkey isn't into the whole sacrifice
thing because he's just a monkey.
You know?
And so you can catch him as a
consequence of his own,
an regulated hypothalamic desires to be.
What would you say,
charitable to the Monkey,
if you put out candy or something like
that.
So like how often does a monkey get
candy?
He's probably a little more motivated
than you are to not let go,
but you can get the point.
The monkey catcher can just walk over to
the jar and pick up the monkey.
The animal will not sacrifice the part
for the whole.
That's actually a pretty good phrase.
Hey,
it's the animal that will not sacrifice
the part for the whole.
Perhaps this story is apocryphal,
but as an eccentric psychology professor
once told me,
fiction lies to you in the most truth,
in the most truthful possible manner,
something valuable given up ensures
future prosperity,
something valuable,
sacrificed,
pleases the Lord.
Those are equivalent statements.
One's more articulated.
I would say.
That's the first statement.
And the second one is more dramatic and
more embedded in a collective religious
dream.
You might say,
what's most valuable and best
sacrificed?
Well,
obviously that depends on the culture
and the time.
What is it least emblematic of that?
A choice cut of meat?
Well,
if you're a herdsmen,
for example,
that that's a big deal.
I mean,
generally speaking,
throughout human history,
meat has been a very valuable commodity
as it is,
by the way,
among chimpanzees.
Chimpanzees hunt,
they like to hunt,
call us monkeys,
and you know,
they'll,
they'll basically start eating the damn
monkey lie.
They weigh about 40 pounds despite the
fact that the thing is screaming away,
and that's pretty interesting because
one of the things that indicates is that
male monkeys mailchimp's,
they're the ones that do the hunting,
aren't really inhibited that much when
they're in fear mode by what you might
describe as empathy and there's certain
elements of human behavior are
reminiscent of that.
You see that sort of thing have merged
now and then in human battlefields when
groups of men seem to abandoned all
internal regulation whatsoever,
to a degree that makes you wonder if
internal regulation even exists.